my guest this week here in Tel Aviv is
the former Israeli prime minister a hood
omote he ordered an invasion of Gaza in
2008 what are his thoughts now about the
recent violence along the border and a
first for an Israeli prime minister he
went to jail for corruption how is it
that he has no regrets
[Music]
I heard omits welcome to convict zone
thank you you said the other day while
the violence on the Gaza border was in
full swing that the Palestinians could
still make a peace deal with Israel if
they could seize the opportunity of a
deal with Trump
you seriously think any Palestinian will
seize the opportunity we now have a
thousand Palestinian children injured by
gunfire from your soldiers you really
think they're gonna make peace with a
country that does that that's a complex
question so let's try and divide it into
the different components okay let's deal
with the values first I'm very much
disturbed by the events in the border
with Gaza on the one hand there is no
question that Israel can't afford to
have all these thousands of people
penetrating into the part of Israel
which is recognized by the entire
international community to be Israel
it's not just mean it's not a thousand
kids only there were tens of thousands
of people and they were indeed there
were many casualties and there were 62
people killed and I'm terribly sorry and
said about it and I also have serious
questions as to what are the appropriate
patterns of response to the illegal
attempt to penetrate into Israel is it
necessary to use the guns the way they
were used snipers the way they were used
you have reservations about the lethal
force that was I have questions I have
questions I have wonders I have doubts
yes because the results speak for
themselves don't they yes how many
injuries how many deaths on the Israeli
side if it was such a mortal threat to
the State of Israel
no one
no one says that this was a mortal
threat to the State of Israel but that's
the condition under which your use to do
whether whether you're supposed to do
when tens of thousands of people want to
cross the border enter illegally into
your country what do you want to do what
can you do what would you do what would
you do in your own country
hit thousands of people from another
country from a hostile country from an
unfriendly country try to penetrate into
your country would you not try to stop
them how to do it exactly what is the
amount of force you can use is a
question that needs to be asked at the
end of the day don't pretend to argue
and I hope you don't that the other side
is made of angels this is Hamas an
organization recognize children you know
shoot children you don't separate the
children from the crowd that was trying
to they're separated by international
and they are encouraged and they were
pushed to go by terrorists Hamas
terrorist says we have reminded Israel
it is imperative that lethal force only
be used as a last resort and when
strictly unavoidable in order to protect
I suggested in the beginning when you
asked me I suggested that we will first
of all recognize the fact that this was
an attempt to illegally penetrate into
another country which has legally to be
stopped
and the other issue is exactly how you
do it and what amount of force you use
it that I said I have my own questions
about the way it was done and I hope
that I will get a appropriate answers
for my side what am I happy I'm very
unhappy about the outcome was it
inescapable was it essential was there
no other way I don't know I doubt I want
to deal with one other thing you said
about Gaza
you also said Israel had left Gaza
cleared added settlements left it all
behind but that's not the full story is
it I mean you control almost every
crossing you control everything that
goes in or out you control the
population registry you control the
public utilities you destroyed the
airport so you've control the airspace
you control the sea space so you haven't
left Gaza you stood outside the cage
instead of inside first of all we need
pull out from Gaza and you remember I'm
sure you do this was not simple and easy
we mean the State of Israel it was part
of the very painful domestic campaign
against tens of thousands of Israelis or
hundreds of thousands who opposed the
government move even to do that so it
was not simple and easy and the problem
is and this is the tragedy is that
unfortunately Gaza is controlled by
terrorist organization by Hamas which is
manipulating the population in a
population we located we first of all I
think that Gaza is first and foremost a
victim of a terrorist organization Hamas
just as Lebanon is a victim in other
ways by a terrorist organization
Hezbollah they are controlling it they
are threatening it
they are building tunnels they are
shooting rockets at the Israeli
settlements across the border but you
don't its way you enforce you around
Gaza and the UN says you're still afraid
I know whatever the UN is not
necessarily a reflection of an objective
judgment of the situation so don't bring
me the UN as an example for objectivity
and for decency with regard to the State
of Israel but I want to go the view of a
lot of countries as you know and human
rights giving me the chance to say where
I may perhaps agree with you sir to some
extent so let me
I said that number one Gaza is
controlled by terrorist organization and
we have to take all the necessary
measures to defend Israeli population
from the terrorist attacks by rockets by
violent tunnels as they are doing that's
number one now is the Israeli attitude
towards Gaza is the smartest I'm not
certain about it can we do it in a
different way I think we can consider
doing it in somewhat different way this
is this is a long way from when you dig
in in 2008-2009 Operation Cast Lead
isn't it you don't want to hear what may
be in contradiction to your prejudices
but I want to say what I think I have
questions and the challenging questions
but you don't count them to those if you
let me read you this I think that we
have to change the relations with Gaza
in as much as it doesn't jeopardize the
security of the State of Israel now
don't ask me about 2008 you belong to
the past
I want to belong to the future in 2008 I
tried as much as I could to reach an
agreement with Hamas and the was an
agreement accepted in June of 2008 for
wouldna
for an unofficial ceasefire he clustered
exactly two days until it was violated
by Hamas winds when 60 rockets were
shorted Ashdod Ashkelon their Sheba when
a million people were sitting in
shelters in order to defend themselves
from those 60 men we had many we had we
had quite a few white men 2030 until
until we all set for two months of our
one month in shelters and it was
thirteen hundred and ninety why peoples
in holding 300 children where they
terrorists as
Tim look bet cemented into the
statistics of the Hamas which I don't
have to subscribe to I'm telling you
this and this is I don't know I don't
know who statistic is this I know one
thing that Israeli cities were shot at
by rockets coming from Gaza hundreds
thousands of them for a long period of
time and the first obligation of every
government including my government when
I was my minister was to defend the life
of my people sometimes unfortunately at
the cost of life of others the
Palestinians killed nine people you
killed 339 because we are stronger when
we are forced to it was during the
structure the fact remains that a few
months later I started to shoot again
Rockets although we do not instead of
trying to talk to us on the basis of
accepted principles that were defined by
the international community you may not
remember but if we go back since you go
back to 2008 we define the three
principles and then I said if these
principles will be accepted by Hamas it
was accepted by the international
community I will negotiate with Hamas I
didn't say that I'll never sit with them
and talk to them in order to resolve the
outstanding issues between us and them
in Gaza in a peaceful manner they
refused to do it they refused to do
military action inside Gaza was
described by your Foreign Minister Tzipi
Livni as real hooliganism
she said Israel demonstrated real
hooliganism in the course of the recent
operation she said that in January 2009
which I demanded she said so my question
to use what happened to that moral army
that Israel is always talking about
the real hooliganism that's you that you
want me to argue with the former Foreign
Minister which said or didn't say I
don't know exactly what she said let me
finish two weeks before an election I
prefer not to do it I don't think that
it is appropriate to go back into these
these arguments going back nine years
ago or ten years ago that your army had
same it is this it seemed that we seen
in the in Gaza it is the simple doctrine
which has characterized the conduct of
every normal and reasonable country use
as my let me finish which is when you
are attacked by rockets into your cities
you have to defend yourself now that you
have to use disproportion we have damage
and we have to use for disproportion
that we have you this is you this no
gaudy Eisen coat your current army
chiefs pelted out in 2009 when he talked
about your second war in Lebanon he said
what happened in that I hear quarter of
Beirut in 2006 will happen in every
village from which shots are fired on
Israel we will use disproportionate
force against it and we will cause
immense damage and destruction gives the
game away doesn't look number one indeed
in order to detail terrorists killers
murderers from continuing the endless
attacks against innocent civilians
sometimes you have to use this
proportionate force in all the tests of
them we did it successfully in Lebanon
the number of casualties was minimal
relative to the force that we used in
the dacha in the Beirut there were not
too many casualties but the whole
neighborhood was destructed destroyed at
that time and it would have been
destroyed again had they
started to shoot against innocent
civilians in those part of Israel now
you live with this huge loss of life
very big but that is that is caused by
you order know if you live with it is it
was caused by the fact that my people my
citizens children in Israel children in
Israel innocent children in Israel were
attacked you sleep more easily because
they know but when my my children are
not attacked by rockets coming from that
side
they sleep better yes and they have to
sleep better and that's no I I don't
want to I don't want to cause the loss
of life all foreigners and sometimes I
don't I don't deny that the outcome of
the counter-attack which was unavoidable
in order to defend us cause the : loss
of life of other people and some of them
are innocent unfortunately and I regret
it and I'm sad about it and as I said at
the beginning regarding the events that
you mentioned of last week in this
context I think that we have to consider
other options of operations which will
be less violent
let's talk about Iran Donald Trump was
pressed very hard by the current Israeli
government to junk the nuclear deal
the Prime Minister's Office said it was
a bad deal but for years though and back
to the time when you were Prime Minister
Israel has been tremendously
hypocritical about the nuclear issue
hasn't it telling Iran not to pursue its
program but refusing to come clean on
the nuclear program that many experts
are satisfied that that you have and
they and the missiles nuclear missile
I'm not familiar with and I don't want
to comment about it because I don't
think that I should comment about it you
let the cat out of the bag anyway didn't
you November
December 2006 you told a German TV
station Iran openly explicitly and
publicly threatens to wipe Israel off
the map can you say this is the same
level when they are aspiring to have
nuclear weapons as America France Israel
and Russia so you gave now an a
wonderful perfect answer to the question
and I wonder why did you have to ask the
question if you have such an answer what
is the comparison between Israel and
Iran Israel whether they have nuclear
weapons or not and I'm not going to talk
about it never threaten to use it
against anyone
Iran openly and publicly throughout all
these years including from 2006 and
earlier to this day threatened to wipe
out Israel from the neck so do you
wonder why we are concerned about the
possibility of Iran having nuclear power
no that's that's that's not the point
okay Bhakra sees for what is worth are
trying to tell the rest of the world
that being a nuclear power has
responsibilities who is Israel to
maintain this what you call a strategic
ambiguity when you demand that everyone
else comes clean about everything and
everyone that threatens to wipe out
another country from the map you you
think they trust you you know and you
trust them you ignore did we ever
threaten Iran of anything did we ever
say that we want the threat can be
implicit or spoken can't it when you
have it explicit you wring it out from
your notes easily but you don't have it
it's because it doesn't exist we never
threatened Iran we never wanted to wipe
out any country from the map and Iran
repeatedly and continuously for many
years is doing precisely Paris said that
Israel wouldn't be the first to
introduce nuclear weapons into the
Middle East that's not true is it that's
simply not true
Jimmy Carter said in 2008 you had them
and he said in 2014 you had between 150
and 300 warheads who say to Jimmy Carter
and he said now I wish to McCarter the
very best I'm not sure that he knew what
he was talking about in 2014 and I don't
think that he was aware of any facts
regarding the Israeli nuclear
capabilities or the lack of them in any
time earlier he said that he said many
things that they didn't agree with he
does know and I don't know so I can't
confirm it US intelligence was convinced
by 1975 according to declassified
documents in Washington that even though
they refused to tell this to Congress
that you had nuclear weapons by 1974
they want me to argue with what was said
in 1975 but that long ago look there
were so many nonsense stories that were
spread about Israel and about Israel
capabilities and what we have and we
don't eat what we don't have and I think
it would be flowers from it will be sort
of flowers entirely to argue with this
look Israel said that we will not be the
first to introduce nuclear weapons to
the Middle East Israel never said that
we will attack another country in order
to wipe it out of the map Iran said it
and therefore the international
community not just Israel Russia not the
friendliest to Israel China all the
other countries our country let me let
me finish now all of these countries
signed an agreement with Iran to prevent
Iran from possessing nuclear power why
did they do it because they know that if
Iran will possess nuclear power it will
impact a not just a Middle East but the
whole world in a very dramatic manner so
why do you try to argue with me about
the concerns of Israel this is the
concern of all the international
community and as Prime Minister I did
say by the way time and again the while
we will do every possible effort to join
forces with other
country's in order to prevent Iran from
possessing nuclear power this is first
and foremost a responsibility of the
superpowers of the United States of
Russia of China of Great Britain it's a
responsibility of everybody it's a
response particularly when a country
threatens to use its power in order to
wipe out on the map another country and
that's what the Iranians are doing
that's why it is such a concern comes
down to trust as you well know pass the
omelet it comes down to a matter of
trust you're saying the world can trust
you want to can trust Iran how on earth
can anyone trust you if you want to
trust the Iranians it's your problem
I don't let's let's talk about you
mister but you were released from jail
last summer after serving 16 months for
accepting bribes and obstructing justice
but you still claimed you were innocent
absolutely but you couldn't convince the
courts of that could you sometimes it
happens doesn't everyone in jail claim
they're innocent did you ever meet
anybody who said they were guilty I wish
I could give you my book which has is
altogether nine hundred pages
yes but a couple of hundreds talk about
these issues I will not elaborate now
because this is before the time but it
explains precisely why there was miss
justice and why there was a conspiracy
in order to try and put me down
from my position as Prime Minister in
order to prevent what I was trying to do
which would have changed the entire
Middle East and that could have made
history politics is a pretty dirty game
Israel when you look at the record of
senior officials and presidents here who
served time or being disgraced it's it's
a long list isn't it
in fact since 1996 every single Israeli
PM has been investigated on corruption
charges
including the present incumbent Benjamin
Netanyahu Prime Minister incumbent yes
yes I missed income why do you hate him
so much me yeah I don't hate anyone not
even him you told him in an interview
you thought you said in an interview
with Keshet TV he should resign now in
an elegant way go run disappear so that
we don't he
you or those around you that's what I
tell him and that will happen in the end
does it mean that I hate only means that
I'm politically opposed to him I don't
want to go into details it seems to me
to be you talked about his personal
appearance a bit of weave a little glue
to stop the hair where it's been quoted
repeatedly on Israeli TV that when I was
investigated Netanyahu kept saying
timing again on television that they
should resign because someone who is
under investigation can perform in such
an sensitive and difficult positions by
ministers so basically what I said is
that what you say to me is definitely
true about you we saw much more of
investigations and accusations and and
suspicions and whatnot but you basically
[Music]
know he is my prime minister I respect
him for his achievements I told him an
amazing failure as Prime Minister he
called you a court certified liar look
it's rough claim Israel do you want me
to quote now some of the statements that
made my British politician against each
other
these are exchanges which take place in
sometimes unfriendly political
confrontations which is typical of most
democratic countries I wouldn't now
quote for president Trump the incumbent
in America said about his opponent his
opponent about him so what you can swing
from Giants I came as I entered no
change no regrets nothing no regrets no
only only sadness for mistakes which
were made by me I definitely made
mistakes you don't think you shamed the
office no Minister no I don't think that
this is the attitude of the Israelis to
me on the country you go to the street
in you ask people and they will tell you
they think that I was a good Prime
Minister and I write by
I think I did some good things and I
wanted to do more good things there were
reasons why I was so fiercely opposed by
particular sections when I was my
minister regrettably but I think that
what I did was very important in some
very sensitive areas security of the
State of Israel and the welfare of the
people of Israel and you're not a crook
and I'm very proud of my achievements
and this is not what people think about
me never good to have you comfort so
thank you very thank you very much thank
you
[Music]